hey everybody welcome back to the park
attacked
today with the ursa miner and the black
hole in the distance
we have to take a look at timber creek
which is
a little bit of an unusual scenario i
suppose
the description is that this is a small
blob of land nearby a rustic sawmill
that provides a charming location for a
few roadside attractions
the land owner is willing wait need to
click that the landowner is willing to
grant you more space but only if you
prove that you're able to put the land
to good use by attracting a large number
of guests
and you can't charge any park entrance
fees now i don't
worry so much about that last point but
you may read here that
you only get more land if you get a
certain amount of guests and this is
where
this crazy list of goals come in but
i pressed the wrong button hold up
absolutely nothing went wrong there
and i just loaded an empty map here we
go so
this is what we start off with just a
very small plot of land you can even see
that the entire map is
really tiny so we're somehow going to
have to get
about 100 guests into this little square
and then we get a small
expansion to it and that'll just
continue all the way until we have 600
people
so it's going to be a bit of challenge
this one it's definitely going to be
very tight
we're going to have to shuffle and
puzzle a lot where certain rides go
try and build as compact as possible and
i think it will be
doable given the roster of rides that
we're going to get here
so we have of course some smaller
coasters but also the monorail coaster
which is
one of the best coaster types especially
if you're
playing with a limited amount of space
but then also some decent flat rides
that are also decently thrilling so
hopefully
we'll be able to make something out of
this the theme is just a generic
kind of midwestern wooden log house
theme
so nothing too special i think i won't
have to experiment too much with that
it's really going to come down to the
gameplay challenge in this map
and trying to figure out how to make all
of these hundreds of guests fit into
this small space
so without further ado let's get started
by the way if you were wondering what
that cut was at the start of this video
i do have save files of the scenarios
just
through me doing a little bit of beta
testing while making these
so accidentally i loaded into that thing
better not do that in the future
but you know we're here in a clean slate
time to try something new
and see where this map takes us now
obviously
we start out with very little space so
i'm not even thinking about building a
roller coaster yet usually roller
coasters are
sort of my starting ground but in this
case i really want to see if i can
fit in some flat rides get to 100 guests
then
get some extra land and start building a
coaster on that and
see how to go from there so i think
that's probably the best way to to go
about doing this
but obviously i also need something of a
food court some information kiosk and a
toilet building as well so these are the
the bare necessities we're getting out
here at the start
and just because we already have that
starting storage building conveniently
placed in that location i decided to
just attach
some shops and stalls to it and also
that staff room so that helps out a lot
i also realized just now that this map
kind of resembles silica slopes
from the original game which is another
scenario where you have very limited
space
some although slightly more difficult
than here
terrain to work with and also a very
similar theme
with the kind of timber frame wooden
buildings
i think the only difference here and
this is something that honestly
i think i discovered this trick while
making this map
i used the adventure pieces for the
roofs so you can see some sort of roof
tile texture
on these and that's a trick that i've
sort of
kept using ever since i made this map
but this
is where i originally discovered that
they kind of work as that
oh and i also figured the original
boring park entrance building is not
going to cut it
so let's build a little tower kind of
like you see in some of those south
german towns where you have these
gates at the edge of the city one
example i think is
freiburg it has a couple of these gate
towers that look really cool
i remember one of them looking so
awesome and like really well preserved
from the medieval era
and then there's a mcdonald's right next
to it i forgot which of the city gates
it was but
it is definitely quite the scene but
it's it's mostly that kind of
architecture that i'm inspired by here
although i guess i did place a food
court next to it so
maybe i took a little bit more
inspiration than i want to give it
credit for
anyway after that i decided to put a
star-shaped flat ride down because it's
always a great flat ride not just
because it looks really great and it's
fun to
to watch go around it also is one of
those flat rides where you can ask
quite a price for people to enter it it
delivers enough of a thrill for
the thrill-seeking guests to not start
getting bored and destroy everything
so all around it's a pretty good ride to
place it's also a ride that you don't
usually get at the start of a scenario
too often so the fact that it's already
here at the start
is something to take advantage of this
scenario
has a lot of challenges but research is
definitely not one of those
as you can see at the start we have
already quite a few
uh rides at our disposal so that
definitely helps
and of course this wouldn't be a
scenario without a ferris
a ferris wheel what am i saying a
merry-go-round at the entrance plaza
so that just after you go through that
door at the
entrance gate you first have the
information kiosk
and then a merry-go-round i'm not sure
if this is
you know roller coaster tycoon history
or if this is just
really realistic theme park logic i find
there are many theme parks that start
off with a merry-go-round near the
entrance and of course information
services are always near the entrance as
well but
it tends to be something that works in
games like this
really well as well so that's that's a
so never a bad tactic
i guess and then over here i decided to
play a little bit with
some symmetrical setup with this ferris
wheel
but put it next to the river have maybe
a little bit of a view of the park
also hopefully when this park is a
little bit more established and
expanded once we get a couple hundred
guests this ferris wheel will be
somewhere in the middle of all of that
chaos so a good place to look at
everything
and also a nice little yeah symmetrical
garden setup with the paths here
down into that ferris wheel i'm gonna do
something like a waterfall
in the water between those parts at some
later stage um but for now it's just a
nice way to lead into the ferris wheel
it's almost like i'm trying to cram some
of the logic
of parks like walibi and disney into a
very
tight small space here uh and that's
essentially what i'm getting at
with this entrance area here
scenery-wise
it's all still trying to follow as much
as possible the
the theme of the original building but i
do want to add a little bit more
you know variety to it and here with
this little roof cover over the queue
line
i discovered that putting a couple of
dormers together is actually a really
great way to make a little spire
and it's something that i've never
really realized i've always put these
dormers
in roof pieces or in you know larger
spire structures but never just the
dormers together but it works
surprisingly well i might actually start
doing that a little bit
more but yeah for this building i
figured it would be a
nice way to add a variety on the
standard 2x2
building cover you know there are so
many building types
typologies if you will that keep coming
back in different scenarios because they
just
always work like a two by two building
covering
some paths or a q line or a three by two
gabled building covering a zigzag queue
line
those are like the typical building
elements that you'll always find in real
life theme parks but
also work really well in the game but
i'm always trying to
add some kind of flair or difference to
them whenever i'm building it
um so even though you always get back to
doing the same stuff because it's just
the winning team that works so i change
anyway
it's always fun to see if you can add
some small variations and i think
the same goes for a lot of the other
architecture in this park as well like
this little house here
brings back the colors and the pieces of
the entrance building
but at the same time with different
heights different
ways of putting the wooden beams
together and different details around it
so
everything's just slightly different
now as you see we got a hundred guests
in the park
and that means that we've automatically
unlocked a whole new section of land
so as you can tell you don't even have
to buy any land yourself
and like i say you don't even but i
guess it's more of a limitation
instead you just get assigned a new
piece of land to build on
so you gradually start expanding so for
this strip of land we get
this whole part here next to the park
that we already had
so this is part of the reason i didn't
want to you know
build the sides to be too closed off you
really have to
yeah kind of work out with this map how
you're going to expand your park because
you always need to
keep some pathways open just in case you
get the land behind some of the rides
that you've built
once you reach another milestone so you
always have to keep
even though it's a very crammed layout
you always have to keep it very open as
well
to add on extra expansions in the future
but for this one i knew of course where
it was going to end up so
i kept this space over here just to
build this coaster in there
i'm on a rail coaster of course with a
pretty simple layout the kind of
standard drop
a zero g roll into an immelman and
yeah a hill overbank turn small airtime
hill and then it's already into the
brakes not that many elements
but i feel like it delivers at least a
decent and realistic enough layout in
this tight space
and besides it's very efficient it has
nine car trains and it can do a lot of
these as you can see
especially in the time lapse so this is
gonna have to be the money maker
this thing is really gonna have to carry
me as i start placing more and more
flat rides because in the end with this
map i really mostly want to put
different flat rides together
to conserve as much space as possible
i did decide though to play a little bit
more with rock work
and now that i'm doing this i'm starting
to wonder why i haven't done this more
in the past
usually i stuck with rock work mostly
around rides or
around water elements things like this
but here i figured i might as well kind
of embellish
these lines of terraforming with
rockwork instead because i
couldn't really come up with anything
else to do with them
to make them look a bit nicer and i'm
actually really happy with
how it turned out i would almost terrace
a whole map like this
i think the only downside is that it
does take a little bit of effort
and especially in scenario play rocks
are not that cheap
and if you make them larger and sink
them into the ground you still have to
pay for the whole rock
and they do get more expensive if you
enlarge them so
it's something you can only start doing
once you're making a decent bit of money
but as you can see in the bottom left
corner that monorail coaster is making
more than just a little bit of money so
it's uh it's already uh working
out very well there now as for the
station
i'm just bringing back in the uh style
of the entrance building
and as i say that i've got another 100
guests in the park thanks to the monroe
coaster so it can expand
a little bit more it's funny how when
you built that ride
on the on the side of the park you can
see the uh
the space shots kind of uh drop tower
that's it i'm saying spatial because
that's what it's called in the molib
anyway when you build it on the side
like a diagonal
park boundary on the water it almost
looks like you're building out of bounds
because
well the you can see that it's it's
going over the actual border but that's
just because it
it's drawn diagonally there over the
water
but it was kind of a funny detail like
when i was looking at that i thought
there would be no way that i could place
that right there because it would be
outside of the park boundaries but turns
out it's still safe
so you know i went with it but it's also
one of those
great flat rides to conserve space but
at the same time attract more guests so
as you can see
i'm already nearing 300 guests in the
park without even having to add
much more to the park so at this point i
decided i could kind of sit back
relax on the rides departments and start
building a little bit more scenery
because the park is getting large enough
with that extra plot of land once we get
300 guests in the park
to try and focus a bit more on scenery
so this is going to be a little bit of a
thematic intermission here as i start
building
somewhat of a town on the side of the
river
obviously this is still a theme park so
there's not too much space to work with
to build buildings
but i did want to build somewhat of a
village-like atmosphere here
and besides even though the other food
court is nearby
i figured it would be nice to have
another building that's large enough to
house a separate depot with some other
food stalls
add some variety to the the food stuffs
in the park
and also make sure that people never go
hungry and angry
because i need this park rating to be as
high as possible
so that i can get more guests get more
space
get more money build more rides and uh
finally
eventually get to the goal and
because i wanted to have that sort of
village look i i couldn't stop myself
from building a small spire here nothing
too special
but you know with this this wooden
boardwalk-ish area overlooking the water
i figured if i was gonna make a small
mini weenie
out of here of any building it's
definitely going to have to be this
building so
ended up placing this here and yeah
that's where we
are right now let's just take a quick
look and see how things are going
so here's where we're at right now and
as you can see
i'm making a steady bit of money but i'm
not really gaining guests anymore so i'm
gonna have to
start working again on some new rides
but as you might notice i'm also trying
to keep some areas a little bit more
open
and this is kind of my personal theory
that i always like to come back to a lot
but
i feel like parks that are completely
busy you know
don't really work out as well nearly as
well as parks that have some
really busy and crowded and crammed
areas and some more open areas
so with this scenario i'm trying to
create some areas where i try to
cram as much together as possible but
maybe also some
more open scenery focused areas like
over here and just have some open grass
just to
get some sort of contrast and make it
seem like it's not just a whole map with
rides everywhere
just thrown at random so that's kind of
my
spatial approach to this build and let's
quickly do a pov
perfect timing thank you very much of
the monorail coaster people are
willing to pay ten dollars for what is
essentially a 20-second ride
but you know i'll take it it's uh it's
all very
essential money for my enterprise
but yeah it's it's kind of like the the
standard
rmc raptor experience in a very tight
small mini layout a little bit slow
on this element here but i think it's
just doable you get some nice airtime
some over bank and a small pop of air
time into the brakes
the short layout also does help with
throughput as you can see
we're just constantly cycling guests
through
i could even do it a little bit more if
i extended the station
but i figured that would just look out
of scale with uh
with how small this park is but yeah
that's uh oh yeah and also i put a
little
sign out here i'm still not sure if i
want this to be called this way
but this part kind of gave me faux
german vibes if you will like some kind
of park
in the united states that's trying to
appear german
but it's really in the u.s and i don't
know for some reason
a mix of german and english in a single
word
kind of made sense to me for that
setting i don't know if i'll keep it
that way
but i always forget that signs are a
thing and they're one of the coolest
things in this game i feel and
very underutilized by me especially so
i'm gonna have to
remember that's a thing and put more of
them down
anyway let's get going start building
some more rides maybe also some roller
coasters because i have been doing
research
and see what we can do
alright so for my next project i am
building a spinning coaster
because of course for all of the
coasters of this scenario i'm trying to
come up with the cosa types that can
deliver a decent amount of excitement
and intensity
while not using too much of a footprint
and
i feel like the spinning coaster is one
of the easiest
targets for this especially in this case
i'm also trying to build my coasters as
much as possible on land that is unfit
for flat rides because i need all of my
flat space
to get as many flat rides and food
stalls and parts in as possible
so this is the kind of ride that you can
build with just a low
enough layout to have it meander with a
few helixes
over some unsteady terrain so i figured
it was pretty much the perfect coaster
type
for this piece of land here now at first
i was
building this very small layout as you
can see with just
two curves into a break run and two more
curves into the station
eventually i realized that this is just
a little bit too conservative
um with all of the layouts that i'm
building i'm trying to
reach somewhat of a compromise you know
obviously i can't build
the full scale layouts that i would like
to build in a full large park but at the
same time i don't want these layouts to
be too
obviously affected by the the small
amount of land that we have available
here so
i'm trying to kind of basically do what
typical spinning coasters do
just a little bit less of it i suppose
so whereas most spinning coasters of
this type of cursed lower or
marasona in real life would have three
four or five block sections
this one's really just two blocks two
main blocks between the lifter and the
final brake run
with just one mid course brake one which
is a little bit short and a little bit
boring but it feels like it's at least a
realistic layout in terms of what it
does
the kinds of speeds it gets you know it
doesn't go into crazy small
curves or tight compact maneuvers that
you don't see in real life on these
coasters so in that sense i feel like
it's a decent compromise to make
i'm also hoping that this coaster will
be enough to
give me another 100 guests into the park
somehow
even if i have to push it a little bit
because as you can see
i am quickly running out of space and
space gets
increasingly harder as you go through
this scenario because
well you get more land for every 100
guests that enter the park
but the land that you get consecutively
gets smaller
with every goal so you know the amount
of land you get when you get 100 guests
in the park is decent but
the one that you get when you have 400
guests in the park is already a lot
smaller so
it gets a little bit more difficult as
you go and then of course the final
stretch from 400 to 600 guests which is
the final goal
you don't get any extra land so you're
gonna have to get those 200 guests in
the end
all on your own so i'm really trying to
prepare as much as possible there
so what i figured i could do for this
piece of land which i just got for my
last milestone and which is going to be
the last expansion of the park
is probably just to build a launched
steel coaster
again it's one of these pieces of land
that's very
heavily terraformed it's not quite flat
enough to put flat rides on
um it's a little bit of an unwieldy
shape as well
so i figured if i was going to build my
final roller coaster anywhere it had to
be over here
i didn't want to snake it through any
other areas that i'd built up
or the only other smaller part of the
park that's still available
and the steel coaster is just perfect
for this kind of thing and i guess it's
kind of the reason why i saved it for
last because it's
the coaster that can most snugly fit
into any kind of space
you don't need it put a lift hill
anywhere you just
have a launch and figure out whichever
elements you can fit into the space
decently
have a break run and call it a day so
that's basically what i'm doing here
we launch into a very strange
inversion that i don't really have a
name for but you know i thought it
worked
it's it's kind of like a sidewinder if
the second
well no it's kind of like a sea serpent
roll if the second part of the sea
serpent
was spinning the other way around and
wasn't a corkscrew but an inline twist
that sounds horrible but in coaster
terms i guess it's as close as we get to
a decent definition of what this
inversion is
i do think it could be fun though i
don't think anything like this exists on
the real life coasters and i've watched
many povs in my day but
if you've seen anything like it then do
comment down below if i've missed out on
any
insane povs but it's definitely a little
bit of a strange element here
but after that i couldn't really figure
out what else to do i tried fitting in
some more
inversions but it was just really hard
to build anything through the inversion
that i'd made
so i ended up just building two helixes
and then one final curve into the brake
run
and the brake run itself is quite far
away from the station just to make sure
that i have enough space to put that
riptide there
because i'm really gonna have to put as
many flat rides in as
i possibly can and i think this also
comes back to the idea of
in a very small park trying to
concentrate some rides and buildings as
much as possible while trying to keep
some areas more open
you can see around the coaster there's
definitely some space left i didn't
completely fill
in every tile but then you come down
here and you have a bunch of buildings
next to each other
a flat ride that is nestled within the
brake run and
a single building that shares the
entrance for both the flat ride and the
coaster you know it's all very tight and
compact
and at least personally i like seeing
these kinds of things you know that
you're not
really using every tile in the in the
park
to its maximum potential but you're
really you know
focusing the the busyness in in some
parts of the map if that makes any sense
so this is just going to have to be a
very busy and heavily themed
area i can also imagine that it's going
to be a nice
sight line when you're walking on that
pier from the village
as i'll call it down to this coaster you
can really see that
tower of this station loom in the
distance
which of course this being parchitect
and this being an isometric game
doesn't really matter too much because
we don't get to see that perspective
at least not without any mods and of
course i'm trying to keep this
as vanilla as possible but it's still
the kind of thing that you know i like
to think about when i
look at these isometric parks but also i
think this building nicely closes out
the village that we have next to the
river here
and honestly this village was very
inspired by
shy guys old scenery it's just something
that
is is lodged in my head for some reason
and i can never get it out and it's it's
something that i always return to
whenever i think of any kind of
alpine but also vermont like wooden
style
american architecture his custom scenery
sets from rollercoaster tycoon are
still influencing me today and it's it's
funny honestly how
he's even returned uh to foreman in
parking
and made some amazing sets for this game
as well
which again given the fact that i'm
playing vanilla on these scenarios
is something that i'm not using but his
shy guys
alpine village work in parkitect is
amazing as well
i get the question so often when i'm
actually going to do something sandbox
in parkitect and i'm sorry if i've
talked about this a little bit too much
but i feel like i might as well segue
into this topic
it's something that i would like to do
at some point in the future but i really
want to finish the scenarios first
so for now it's out of the question but
it's it's definitely something that i
want to try in the future especially
if and when i do run out of scenarios to
play so
that's uh that's something i'm playing
for the long con
um also i'm pretty sure i just forgot to
mention that i built a flat right there
but yeah i built the the big
loop-de-loop flat ride
uh in that corner of the park and that
pretty much fills up the
entire scenario at this point all i'm
still doing is adding some final touches
waiting for the countdown to reach 600
guests which i think i'll
comfortably reach especially given the
fact that i'm running some
advertisements now so i'll see some
extra people come in
the looping coaster or i should say the
steel coaster is very good at drawing in
extra guests so that's really nice as
well
so at this point i really just have to
pause the game sometimes make sure i'm
not reaching the core
too quickly like i did in candyland and
trying to
to fill all of the nooks and crannies
and finish the last little bits of this
park
before i uh before i reach the end goal
so nothing too spectacular happening
here i decided to add one more
toilet building next to the the launch
drop tower
just because i i only had one sort of
near the entrance
and i felt like it would fit to to put
one in there as well
i think it's also good to have two
different core
uh food courts in the scenario so we
have one in the village as well
it's just something to to make people go
to that area and sit on the benches and
have some food
sometimes you know it's not even all
about the the gameplay
uh part of it but just about how it
looks and
it's always nice to have different food
courts throughout your park and just
see people enjoying their day and
finally
my my last touch which is kind of
unusual for me to build a coaster and
then actually finish it later on
i decided to build a station for the
spinning coaster
and this is a square station doesn't
happen a lot but you know this being a
spinning coaster
you don't need a huge station for it
mostly some block sections so i decided
to
put some simple cap shaped roof on that
little spire
and finally we have a seating area
this is actually i think the the second
ceiling area already for this scenario
just some benches and a path and a roof
over it to take in the views around you
and that's basically it so let's go back
and see how it turned out
all right so there we are i'm not going
to let another candy land scenario
happen this time
oh now there we go
all right perfect i like how every
scenario is actually an achievement on
steam as well that's very funny
anyway we made it um
although we didn't make it by the end of
october year two i actually didn't
notice
oh that's very difficult all right
didn't get the optional goals this time
then
uh but at least i made it and honestly
i'm pretty happy with how it turned out
given the goals of this scenario i don't
think it's particularly hard
to finish the scenario but i did see a
bit of a challenge in finishing it in a
decent manner where the park doesn't
look
you know too roller coaster tycoon micro
parky
but i think this uh this manages to
strike a balance let's do a quick pov of
the spinning coaster
and by quick i really mean quick because
it's it's not the biggest coaster ever
but i feel like it does a decent amount
of stuff in its layout
and then we get to that small break run
it's almost like a station fly by
honestly
at this point and they fly over over the
water
which actually does spin the best for uh
most of the ride these these cars don't
actually spin as much
and to be honest i haven't done a test
but it seems to me like they spin a
little bit
less than the gerstlauer cars these are
the the real life equivalents maurer
sauna cars
whereas with gerstlauer you're sitting
uh in in a in an eye to eye seeding
two across which is really fun if you're
with friends but a little bit awkward if
you're with strangers
so i i kind of prefer these depending on
who you're with i suppose
uh and then we get the steel coaster
we'll get to that in a minute if we can
actually do a full pov
but yeah all things considered i'm
pretty happy with how it worked out it
really does kind of have that village
vibe
with the river going through the middle
here oh i think we we really have to do
a pv
here now uh pretty sure i set the timing
on this station to be quite
short um but maybe it's not short enough
any second now
all right we'll see how that goes i i do
feel a little bit bad for these people
on the break one ah there we go
i just wanted to have as much throughput
as possible because as you can see
i am reaching maximum capacity on this
ride so i need to get as much throughput
as i can and honestly it doesn't
occur too often that in architect i
managed to hit
the maximum capacity of any roller
coaster but here it happened
i mean the the spinning coaster is a bit
of a an exception because it
of course doesn't have a huge capacity
and this one does
have a pretty decent throughput because
it has two trains and a very short
layout
but you know stuff happens i am making a
very good amount of profit i also
noticed
three thousand dollars a month is not
something that i
usually hit so that's really really cool
to see as well
but yeah that's uh that's basically
timber creek
let's go back to the main menu and see
what we end up
getting as a trophy i suspect it's
probably the
the sawmill right
there we go makes sense all right
so let's see what we get for the next
one
[Music]
god this is such a reveal oh
yeah i know what this is jungle
adventure
all right i'll see you guys in the next
video thanks for watching
and take care bye